ah flat tire yeah I mean I can call my
insurance designer no time
no service yeah me neither I mean we
could change the tire yeah I chase cars
all the time yeah I know how to change a
tire yeah there should be some kind of
believer ah there we go
where's the tire you know what how would
you get started on the tire I'll go
check the engine to make sure this
puppies born
yeah the flux capacitor is all messed up
and you think the hard drive Pratt a
hard drive looks good it's a soft drive
that's making me mad did you check the
flask findell you have a slam rod no
only a twist Pole are you lightning the
McQueen yeah why do you think I asked
for a twist full when was the last time
you put Vin Diesel in this dude Damon
the Affleck do you have a jalopy bipole
I feel like I'd be a lot easier think so
God if you could just please fix this
car it'd be really solid if you'd get us
out of this mess I'll never do anything
bad again I swear I found the rubber
wheel what kind of car is this a 67 Ford
Coppola that's what I thought
damn it Zack are you eating grass I
didn't have breakfast so sorry from a
little hangar just a couple of oil
bunnies a couple dirty gas ferret missed
our wire to carrier b2k you think was
you just 76 to Chevron shell you want to
go have these and opening a shop with me
absolutely all right I think I'm gonna
cut the umbilical cord Oh make sure you
don't cut the fallopian tube I won't
can you just press the car button real
quick carb up okay now take it out of
drift but into pod you want me to
release the stop stick cars totaled
[Music]
no is the problem you drive too much of
cruise control oh that's risky business
is it about to rain man I don't know
looks like Vanilla Sky to me this
mission is impossible maybe I should
file a Minority Report how about we just
keep it under Ghost Protocol keep your
eyes wide shut we're gonna figure this
out I know what you're right where if
you can then do everything about what
kind of wedding dress your wife's gonna
wear one day every day why are we stuck
right now please just miss the guard
guys take me God bring me up to heaven
now ladies and gentlemen we interrupt
this program to bring you some breaking
news
two men were recently found dead on the
side of the road after experiencing some
car trouble the shocking thing is is
that they were exactly point two miles
away from the nearest gas station back
to you Chris
[Music]